[Music]
it's late pitch dark and a self-driving
car winds down a narrow country road
suddenly three hazards appear at the
same time what happens next before it
can navigate this onslaught of obstacles
the car has to detect them gleaning
enough information about their size
shape and position so that its control
algorithms can plot the safest course
with no human at the wheel the car needs
smart eyes sensors that will resolve
these details
no matter the environment weather or how
dark it is all in a split second that's
a tall order but there's a solution that
partners two things a special kind of
laser based probe called lidar and a
miniature version of the communications
technology that keeps the Internet
humming called integrated photonics to
understand lidar it helps to start with
the related technology radar in aviation
radar antennas launch pulses of radio or
microwaves at planes to learn their
locations by timing how long the beams
take to bounce back that's a limited way
of seeing though because the large beam
size can't visualize fine details in
contrast a self-driving cars lidar
system which stands for light detection
and ranging uses a narrow invisible
infrared laser it can image features as
small as the button on a pedestrians
shirt across the street but how do we
determine the shape or depth of these
features lidar fires a train of super
short laser pulses to give depth
resolution take the Moose on the country
road as the car drives by one lidar
pulse scatters off the base of its
antlers while the next may travel to the
tip of one antler before bouncing back
measuring how much longer the second
pulse takes to return provides data
about the antlers shape with a lot of
short pulses a lidar system quickly
renders a detailed profile the most
obvious way to create a pulse of light
is to switch a laser on and off but
this makes a laser unstable and affects
the precise timing of its pulses which
limits depth resolution better to leave
it on and use something else to
periodically block the light reliably
and rapidly that's where integrated
photonics come in the digital data of
the Internet is carried by precision
timed pulses of light some as short as a
hundred picoseconds one way to create
these pulses is with a Mach Zehnder
modulator this device takes advantage of
a particular wave property called
interference imagine dropping pebbles
into a pond as the ripples spread and
overlap a pattern forms in some places
wave peaks add up to become very large
in other places they completely cancel
out the mach-zehnder modulator does
something similar it splits waves of
light along two parallel arms and
eventually rejoins them if the light is
slowed down and delayed in one arm the
waves recombine out of sync and cancel
blocking the light by toggling this
delay in one arm the modulator acts like
an on-off switch emitting pulses of
light a light pulse lasting a hundred
picoseconds leads to a depth resolution
of a few centimeters but tomorrow's cars
will need to see better than that by
pairing the modulator with a
super-sensitive fast-acting light
detector the resolution can be refined
to a millimeter that's more than a
hundred times better than what we can
make out with 20/20 vision from across
the street the first generation of
automobile lidar has relied on complex
spinning assemblies that scan from
rooftops or hoods with integrated
photonics modulators and detectors are
being shrunk to less than a tenth of a
millimeter and packed into tiny chips
that a one-day fit inside a car's lights
these chips will also include a clever
variation on the modulator to help do
away with moving parts and scan at rapid
speeds by slowing the light in a
modulator arm only a tiny bit this
additional device
we'll act more like a dimmer than an
on/off switch if an array of many such
arms each with a tiny controlled delay
is stacked in parallel something novel
can be designed a steerable laser beam
from their new Vantage these smart eyes
will probe and see more thoroughly than
anything nature could have imagined and
help navigate any number of obstacles
all without anyone breaking a sweat
except for maybe one disoriented moose
what happens when self-driving cars
encounter an unavoidable accident how
does the car choose who to protect
explore the ethical dilemma of
self-driving cars with this thought
experiment
[Music]